China has issued a stark warning to
protesters today a government spokesman
in Beijing warned protesters that
punishment was coming and they should
not underestimate the strength of the
central government Hong Kong police also
announced that they had arrested more
than 148 people the largest single-day
tally since demonstrations began two
months ago ago here's some afford
Beijing spokesmen had to say well man hi
we want to warn the handful of violent
criminals and meddling hands behind them
play with fire will perish by it
well the punishment will only be a
matter of time listen straight go to
Beijing and to our correspondent Matias
bourlingueur mighty strong words there
is this meant to be a sharp warning to
those China's calling criminals and
meddlers yes it is meant as a warning
you can imagine if you heard these words
in some mafia movie you would shudder
now and you would expect something to
happen however this is not a mafia movie
and we can also notice that this these
these words did not were not followed by
any specific means that Beijing plans to
implement he did not elaborate on how
these people would perish in the fire
that they have said as he put it so it
is still giving us a hint that Beijing
has not made up his mind on how to react
to these clashes in Hong Kong on how it
should deal with them other than that he
has said that Beijing stands firm behind
Carrie Lam the chief executive and that
it would be Hong Kong's government's
task to resolve this issue so in that
regard there was nothing new with this
press conference
but Amity she did talk about punishment
the Beijing spokesman what kind of
pressure can China use on the protesters
is China preparing to use military force
do you think the threats have been out
for two or three weeks now the PLA the
People's Liberation Army has said they
would be ready to intervene if the Hong
Kong government asked them to intervene
that would be the correct procedure and
has also issued a video that seems to
enact something like washing a protest
in a city today we have seen another
video by the Shenzhen police that's the
city just across the border from Hong
Kong on the Chinese mainland which have
re-enacted scenes that are strikingly
similar to what is happening in Hong
Kong we have seen protesters wearing
hardhats as we have seen in Hong Kong we
have seen a lot of smoke in that case it
was just smoke not teargas in Hong Kong
it's teargas deployed on the protesters
and these police units beating these
protesters so the warning that pay
Beijing might intervene has been out for
some time there are reasons to believe
that Beijing wants to try all other
means that they have before they would
do that because it would bare
considerable consequences on China's
economy on Hong Kong and it's not the
the first thing that they would do if if
they have other options okay notice
before we continue our conversation
let's take a look at what's happening in
Hong Kong
our correspondent Shana Chilton bill was
at the demonstrations last night and
sent us this report on the dramatic
developments there
as soon as we arrived the chaos begins
[Applause]
the tear gas clears protestors slowly
return among them dozens of local
residents many joining chants demanding
police retreat curious bystanders
watching on stunned at the scene
unfolding in this normally quiet
neighborhood police call for more backup
as the mood once again turns dark the
showdown begins
each side waiting for the other to make
the first move
Bo's threatening to tip this standoff
over the edge close to midnight the
police move in
sending people scattering with the
blockade cleared the arrests begin
[Applause]
this is a residential area one woman
screams people here weren't even wearing
face masks more protesters are swept up
as the police round on the stragglers no
one here wanted it to end this way those
arrested face up to ten years in prison
if they're charged with rioting it's a
heavy price to pay for a night on the
streets some artists as we saw in
Charlotte's report a very tense
situation there you yourself have been
reporting on the ground during the
protests in Hong Kong in your assessment
how much impact with today's warning
from Beijing have on the protesters well
what we've clearly seen during these
eight nine weeks that this has been
going on is that deterrence doesn't work
in Hong Kong protesters are very
emotional about this thing there's this
feeling that this might be the last
chance to save Hong Kong from Beijing's
grip there's also this feeling that
anyway people in this city would have no
future
so these youngsters are taking big risks
to do what they think they should do to
prevent Beijing from from taking a
harder grip on the city last week we
have seen more than 40 people arrested
brought to the courts the very next day
charged with rioting which carries a
very heavy sentence in Hong Kong ten
years what we've seen then is more
people coming out protesting at the
police stations attacking the police
stations so I do not think that this
warning will change the course of events
in any way right building in Beijing
thank you very much for that update from
there